[Musica]
[Applauso]
quanti di voi sono stati sulla somma a
visitare i luoghi della grande guerra
delle grandi battaglie della prima
guerra mondiale
alzate la mano
pochissimi
qualcuno di voi sarà stato sicuramente
sul carso oppure qui vicino
sull'altipiano di asiago sul monte
grappa dove è facile trovare le trincee
della prima guerra mondiale visitarle
entrarci
respirare l'odore
della grande guerra
l'attrice ha
la trincea non è solamente un luogo
fisico
un luogo fatto di sangue e merda fango
ma è anche un elemento che sta dentro la
testa dei soldati
e la dimensione della vita della morte
della promiscuità
del cameratismo della paura
dell'orrore
e allora
iniziamo questo viaggio verso e dentro
le trincee della prima guerra mondiale
la grande guerra è una guerra di massa
una guerra industriale
una guerra moderna quella che alla fine
dell'ottocento uno studioso polacco di
origine russa si chiamava ian block
aveva definito la guerra futura
iamm block nel 1898 aveva scritto che la
prossima guerra sarebbe scoppiata entro
15 anni sarebbe durata non meno di
cinque e avrebbe provocato almeno 10
milioni di morti
una guerra che avrebbe devastato
dal punto di vista economico tutte le
potenze belligeranti
sia i vinti sia i vincitori che avrebbe
affamato incivili che avrebbe disgregato
i grandi imperi
sarebbe stata una guerra lunga
non una guerra lampo sarebbe stata una
guerra di trincea una guerra di
posizione non una guerra di movimento
come le grandi guerre le grandi
battaglie napoleoniche d'inizio
ottocento
una guerra combattuta con armi sempre
più potenti e micidiali che avrebbero
aumentato a dismisura
il numero dei morti
dentro le trincee pensate che durante la
prima guerra mondiale vengono costruiti
o scavati 42mila chilometri di trincee
42.000 praticamente la lunghezza della
circonferenza della terra
la grande guerra è un conflitto di
uomini contro macchine la definizione è
di un grande scrittore curzio malaparte
come sapete l'italia entra in guerra nel
maggio del 1915
attraverso quello che è stato definito
un colpo di stato a prendere questa
decisione sono appena tre persone
il re vittorio emanuele iii quello basso
non arrivava praticamente alla misura
per poter fare il servizio militare
il presidente del consiglio antonio
salandra e il presidente e poi che è il
vero presidente del consiglio della
grande guerra che però il ministro degli
esteri sidney sonnino
sidney sonnino
grandissimo personaggio molto
controverso
ebbene tre persone che decidono
l'entrata in guerra dell'italia
sono interventisti gli interventisti
sono convinti che la guerra alla guerra
italiana possa durare poche settimane al
massimo pochi mesi è un conflitto da
chiudere in maniera vittoriosa entro la
fine del 1915
il partito della guerra gli
interventisti
pensano di superare facilmente il
confine di prendersi gorizia e trieste
di puntare su lubiana e poi mettere la
freccia a sinistra in direzione di
vienna
le cose però vanno in maniera molto
diversa
nell'estate del 1915 appena due mesi
dopo l'entrata in guerra
francesco saverio nitti che era uno che
capiva di economia
chiede al presidente del consiglio se ha
provveduto agli approvvigionamenti
invernali per l'esercito
salandra lo guarda stupito e gli dice ma
tu stai scherzando
è vero che tu appartiene al partito dei
gufi
ma tu pensi che la nostra guerra alla
guerra italiana quella che abbiamo
cominciato contro l'austria ungheria
possa durare oltre l'inverno
i primi eletti
vengono dati in dotazione all'esercito
italiano solamente nel novembre del 1915
sei mesi dopo l'entrata in guerra
sono il meti come questi permetti di
fabbricazione francese
all'inizio non avevano questo colore
erano blu
come quelli in dotazione appunto
l'esercito francese e sono eletti che
hanno lo spessore della calotta
inferiore a un millimetro
praticamente la metà
di quelli in dotazione all'esercito
austro ungarico
ebbene durante quei sei mesi quei primi
sei mesi senza questi elmetti
i proiettili le granate le schegge delle
rocce del carso hanno provocato il
ferimento la mutilazione o la morte di
almeno 120 mila soldati italiani
120mila
nel frattempo la mitragliatrice è
diventata la signora della guerra l'arma
simbolo della guerra moderna
l'evoluzione della mitragliatrice e
velocissima molto rapida
una mediatrice e spara fino a 600 colpi
al minuto a un fuoco utile di quasi due
chilometri
i fucili sparano proiettili che superano
gli 800 metri al secondo
i proiettili
arrivano prima che tu possa sentire il
rumore dello sparo
i proiettili arrivano prima che tu possa
sentire il rumore dello sparo
e per questo che nasce l'espressione
tappo un ta è il colpo secco del
proiettile pool è il rumore dello sparo
e questo vi dà la cifra di quanto
moderna sia la prima guerra mondiale
anche la guerra italiana dovrebbe essere
una guerra moderna ma i soldati italiani
non sono per nulla equipaggiati forse
avrete visto vi sarà capitato di vedere
ma lo trovate anche su youtube
nella versione integrale il film uomini
contro un film del 1970 di francesco
rosi un film che tra l'altro è stato
tratto da un grande romanzo romanzo di
emilio lussu un anno sull'altipiano
ebbene in questo film c'è una sequenza
molto particolare in cui un generale che
si chiamava il generale leone manda al
massacro un intero reparto
che è armato solamente di armature
sembrano quasi delle armature medievali
con delle con degli elmi delle corazze
dei gambali di ferro e vengono mandati
nella terra di nessuno
vengono fatti uscire allo scoperto per
tagliare i reticolati e vengono falciati
tutti
dalle mitragliatrici né mite dalle
mitragliatrici
dell'esercito austro ungarico c'è una
carneficina tale che a un certo punto i
soldati dell'esercito austro ungarico si
alzano in piedi e urlano basta soldato
italiano basta farti ammazzare in questa
maniera torna indietro soldato italiano
e questo vi fa capire
non solo la stupidità della guerra
ma anche l'incapacità dei nostri
generali tra il 1915 e il
dita della guerra
ma quanti sono stati i soldati che sono
morti in questa maniera così assurda
i soldati cominciano a morire fin dal
primo giorno di guerra durante i primi
cinque mesi del conflitto
l'esercito francese aperte oltre 300
mila soldati
329 mila per l'esattezza
329 mila morti è come se fosse scomparsa
in cinque mesi
un decimo della popolazione di parigi un
decimo
il primo luglio del 1916 durante la
prima giornata della battaglia della
somma nell'esercito britannico si
contano 19 mila 200 morti
un morto ogni 4 secondi
ogni giorno durante la grande guerra
muoiono sui campi di battaglia
5.632 soldati
5.632 uomini dai 18 ai 42 anni
ogni giorno per quattro anni e mezzo
ogni giorno scompare un pezzo di europa
ma ogni giorno scompare anche un pezzo
d'italia pensate sono 530 tre morti al
giorno
i soldati italiani
qui quanti siamo
stasera dovremmo essere circa 250 ebbene
il doppio di questa platea scompare ogni
giorno
questo per tre anni e mezzo
i morti
hanno una e naturale quando possono
averne una
ma accanto i morti nelle trincee ci sono
anche i sepolti vivi quelli che stanno
dentro le trincee quelli che aspettano
di andare all'assalto quelle che vivono
in minuscole ampolle di vita che sono
circondate da un cimitero senza nome
a ridosso della terra di nessuno
li nelle trincee i soldati vivono
convivono
sopravvivono ai compagni caduti
lettrice sono percorse dall'orrore dei
vivi verso i morti
sono percorse dall'odore acre dei
cadaveri che siete compongono
lo compongono sono percorse dalla dalle
urla strazianti dei feriti che
provengono da terra di nessuno
e questi feriti chiedono ai loro
compagni è solamente una cosa uno sparo
pietoso che metta fine alla loro agonia
la morte di massa è un fatto statistico
e burocratico i morti in fondo sono
numeri
i morti vanno recuperati
contatti
riconosciuti
registrati e infine
forse sepolti
alle autorità militari durante i primi
mesi del conflitto non interessano i
morti le autorità militari sono
solamente preoccupati del fatto che le
salme possano uscire dalla zona
considerata
zona di guerra
sarebbe
devastante per l'opinione pubblica a
venire a sapere che ogni giorno ci sono
oltre 500 morti la stessa cosa
sarebbe impressionante per i soldati che
sono avviati verso il fronte
incrociare dei treni carichi di bare che
tornano verso casa
nel dopoguerra tra l'altro non si parla
di morti
ma solamente di caduti a
tutti
non è un vezzo stilistico
è un modo per esorcizzare la morte in
guerra per togliere l'orrore che questi
soldati hanno vissuto in trincea
ma la trincea ha tolto a questi morti
anche un'altra cosa importante
il nome due terzi dei soldati morti
durante la grande guerra sono ignoti
tecnicamente chi non torna né vivo né
morto e un disperso
e dove sono rimasti questi morti sono
rimasti e nei piccoli cimiteri di guerra
dal pasubio al grappa dal carso al piave
oppure sono immersi nella calce delle
fosse comuni
soldati senza vita soldati senza corpo
soldati senza nome
uomini
abbandonati e dimenticati nella terra di
nessuno
ma né alla fine
rimangono comunque
le memorie
rimangono le vedove rimangono gli orfani
e si deve cercare un modo per ricordare
questi morti
io li chiamo morti non li chiamo caduti
e come possiamo fare noi qui questa sera
oggi a oltre cento anni di distanza per
ricordare quei morti
io me lo sono chiesto spesso nelle mie
ricerche come possiamo fare a ricordarli
c'è un'unica risposta
cominciamo a chiamare questi nomi per
nome con il loro nome e il loro cognome
uno ad uno
di questi libroni
26 mi26
e sono pieni di nomi e tutti i nomi che
sono qui dentro sono morti della prima
guerra mondiale
a balini giuseppe a boffa alberto a
giuseppe accordini francesco acerbi remo
acqua saliente angelo acri alessandro
adami ettore a da anselmo ad aem e gildo
a fili giovanni a freddo giuseppe agazzi
giovanni agazzi mario ager de giulio a
getta silvestro
e così per 650 mila volte
[Applauso]